th
ん
眼帯
いっっ
何杯でもいけますね
美味しい
ここは科学の勝利ですよ
産まないわけないんです
僕は今
一つのプロダクトに対して
美味しいという意思を持ったんですですよねあなたにもありますぱず飲んでみて
ください
思うんですよめっちゃ美味しいななぜか産まないわけないがあるんですよね
大人にいる方も補佐ご質問してあげてください
最近何かおいしいのあったっに言わざるを得ない
だってねうまいからあのジュースめっちゃ美味しかったよってもう言っちゃうわけです
あの十数めっちゃ美味しかったよ
よく見るやつねっ
何気ない日常のひとバックですよこれ
あーなんかうまいの歌ってあこんなあったよ
僕の目には一つのものを介して人と人が意思の疎通を行った瞬間のように
見えたわけです
じゃあ僕も同じようにしています
あいにくと僕の隣には友達がいない
何ステージつの大大講堂蔵もんですから
いつもみんながやってる奴やりますそう
写真を撮るが者って言っ
ツイートしています
これは僕が昨晩実際に投稿した twitter 上のコメントなんですけどこの中の
皆さん
僕のツイート昨晩見てあぁこんな13あるやね美味しそうだねそういうふうに思った方
何名くらいいらっしゃいますか
いない通して当然ですよ僕とも昨晩
タイミングにおいて2いた上で友達の人誰もこの会場にはあいにくといないわけです
僕はそんなに有名じゃないし
つまり僕のこれ美味しかったよ
この石は皆さんには疎通しなかった
今1ヶ月の間に
約3億にが人間がツイッターを使っているというふうに言われるすごい数ですよ
この後は一つの国に換算してみたら日本とアメリカの間ぐらい
超大国
だいたい1日の間に
上戸9回ぐらいコメントが投稿されるらしいんですね
ポンしかも年々増加の糸を立て
素晴らしい
じゃあ質問です今日僕がここに立つまでの間に
さっき僕がやったみたいにものに関するコメントが
美味しいみたいななんでもいいです大体何回くらい投稿されたと思いますか
僕も知らない数えられないし誰か知ってる人いた方教えてください
ただ
今この世の中というのは何か体験した瞬間
楽しい面白い即座に自分の友達に sns を通して拡散できるそんな便利な世の中
じゃないですか
でも僕はこと消費体験においてはそれは
必ずしもベリーですとな方法だとは思わないわけです
今から
ものを通した人と人の
医師の札がどういうふうに行われてきたのかを
過去現在未来と少しです軸をずらしながら僕と一緒に見ていきましょう
まずは江戸時代
この絵はなんでもいいんですよ別にどうでもんって誰だねこれなー
左下にいるじゃないですか彼
青いちゃんちゃんこみたいなきた彼ですそう彼
なんか後夜祭大量に持ってるやつですよこれ
たぶんね百姓か万能カーなんでしょうね
彼が僕 ok ですか僕は
農家です
ちょうど右上にね日本まして書いてありますよね
これ日本橋の絵らしいです
僕今東京の日本橋っていう場所でオフィス構えてるんですね
シンパシーを感じずにいられないあの左下の百姓は僕僕は農家
僕は
キャベツを作るのが非常に上手
これおいしいですかまずいですかもうわかりますよね皆さんね
産まないわけないんです絶対うまいこのキャベツ
度こそ食べてみてくださいってこのお隣さんの彼にを配ったほうがいいんだ
うまい言ってくれるんですよ
食べた瞬間に竹中の作っている風景がフラッシュバックしたアユと言ってくれ
ありがとうございます
次の日僕にあったした時に言ってくれるんだよ
あのキャベツおいしかったよと江戸時代の口コミなんてのは退社後ないですよもう
シンプルです長屋部の色端会議みたいなもんですよなんかこう
奥さん同士がこう選択しながら竹中さんの作ったキャベツ
うまいらしいで愛知てそんなもんですよ
だからそういう風にして口コミもなんか生まれるかもしれないねっ
重要なのはここなっ
もし対面で僕が今キャベツはたして次の遊牧とあったら絶対言ってくれるんです
美味しかっただから僕もよる
ありがとうあつってまたあげるわみたいなやつですね
一つの
商品プロダクトものを通して人と人が意思の疎通を達成した
このシチュエーションを僕は
ものコミュニケーションとそう呼ぶことにします
少しだけ僕の話をさせてください僕は
大学の時に自分で会社を吐く小さい会社小さい会社をつくってそこで
自分でデザインしてブレスレットを作ったことがあるんですよ
結構頑張りましたスタッフの人たちもめちゃくちゃ頑張ってくれた
だから
いいのができたよくないですか我ながらね聞いてきですよ
ね販売代理店舗も20店舗くらいできたんです
僕じゃない店舗さんが代わりに打ってくれるわけです
ある程度売れるわけです
江戸時代には僕はキャベツ食ってたんですよ
ケロ現代ではブレスを作ってるまぁ
メーカーって言われる人に近かったですよね
華麗なるジョブチェンジ素晴らしい
ダラ
僕は自分で作ったブレスレットを
回も実験ぽに立ってお客様に手渡ししたことがないんです
ありがとうございました常だだからたとえ100個200語専攻2000個いくら売れ
ても僕は勝ってくれた人の顔
誰一人として知らないです
言いませんよっぽど
大ヒット商品とかじゃない限り
僕は生産者ですよねブレスるってを買ってくれた人は一般的に消費者と呼ばれます
消費者の方の
ああよかったでみたいな声って生産者までは届かないんです
もう
この規模でも届かない
は excel 見たって何も考えですよ販売のなんかこう何個売れたかみたいな
戦前
売上を上げる方法との書いてないしそのデータをでいくらいくらくわってペラペラ
めくって言っても
結局のところ何色が何個売れたかということがわかるだけでお客様がどう思ってくれ
てるかなんてわからないんです
もちろんこれからどうしたらいいかも分からないでーためだってわかんないですよ
今の世の中は
ハイパー消費社会って言われません聞いたことありますよね社会でならおやつです
ハイパー省社会少しだけ良い帰ってみます
今日はの
セブンイレブンとかで働いている人に会ったらごめんなさいねちょっとラゲームから
悪口みたいなことを言う可能性があります
可能性
今の時代はコンビニ神社会つまり
コンビニ市場主義社会だというふうに今だけ捉えてみてください今だけでいいです
どういうことだと簡単ですあのコンビニとかの pos レジってあるじゃないですか
レジです
一般的なやつあれって実はデータをとって
メーカーさんに販売しているんですねどういうデータが何県の何市にあるコンビニでは
何歳くらいのお客さんで男性やた男性がどんな商品を買って行ったかっていう非常に
定量的といわれるデータを
メーカー者は購入するわけです
じゃあなんで購入するかっていうのは今敏さんに言われるんですよ
ああ次こんな商品くるんちゃいますかあったメーカーさんいいわけですよね
次こんな商品きますはあえて何でこんなことになるか
メーカーさんはねコンビニ商品を言ってもらいたいわけですよ
これおいてくれはったら
売れる可能性があがりませんつまりある程度の財布が担保できるわけ
おいてくれなかったですね売上が下がる可能性がある
シンプルですよねけど
女版ブレスレット作った僕とあんま変わらないですよだって
商品を改善するためにデータを高もらってで定量的な売上のデータでなさいくらい
でしょうかへーこんな子を買ってるなら
で売上を上げていくもしくは商品改善につなげていく
非常に
ロジカルじゃないですか
リーズナブルだし僕は非常にいいと思うんですただ
メーカーさん
は
本当に戦わなければいけないのはコンビの pos レジのデータじゃないんですよ
少なくともあーか別食べてくれて美味しかったよみたいな顔したくなって枯れ枯れ
みたいな表情に
ちゃんとアジャストしていかなければいけない
ちょっとだけプロセスが間違っていると僕は思いました
未来の話をします
まあこの写真はあいにくと橋白紙に戻った方の未来の写真ですけどね
なぜ青い鳥てい
ワンクリックれ者せワンクリックで皆さんの家に商品が届く
違いますかもう待ってクリックしたらすぐもう登録じゃないですか
今の時点で達成できるすごい
もしかしたらもうタワーマンションを30回とかに住んでてからって運動開けたら
ドローンが商品を届けてくれるかもしれねえつってます
考えてみてくださいよもうこんな僕昔キャベツ食ってたんですよ
これでもう
人に手渡しで東海道五十三月のにそんな話じゃないんですよ
すぐに登録テレポーテーション瞬間色の池ですよ
でドローンが届けてくれるなんての首相官邸の上とか豚ない限り起こりそうな未来です
よね実現しそう
けど
んなことしてるとまた分校なるけど
生産者つまりキャベツを作った僕とおいしいねって言ってくれた彼
があまりに距離が離れてしまってもうどんな人がいいとか言ってくれたのでもう見え
ないんですね顔ちっちゃすぎていいとか言ってくれた声なんか絶対取るか偏
んなブラックボックスな状態でいいのが自主わけがない
この
便利な時代をつくったのは
it ですよだからこれを解決するのも僕達 it やだと思うんですね
すごく便利になっていくのはいいんですがそこで人と人の感情の受け渡しをどういう
ふうに工夫するか
まだまだ余裕が残っていると思うんですだから僕は
こういうテーマに身をおいて
どれだけ人と人が離れた生産者と消費者が離れてた
隣に友達がいる方ツイートするそれもいいですけど
そういう状況を解決所その指標が
ものコミュニケーション2.3
そういうふうになつけました
まだまだこのテーマを選んでプロセス
こんなのすぐに解決するわけじゃないし完璧なソリューションが存在するわけでもない
んです
でも今までの
成果として一つの
ソフト僕は開発しました
それがスコアと呼ばれるソフトです
まだまだこれからです不完全だけど
iphone ですから携帯のアプリケーションを立ちあげますよね
例えばこの
美味しかった十数
すぐにカメラが立ち上がりますよこのカメラ立ち上げて
商品がありますよねこのバーコードをスキャンするとカメラの中に世界中から投稿され
たコメントが即座に反映されます
どんな商品でもいいですどんなバーコードでも大丈夫
一度投稿されたら北海道に様が福岡に様が同じコメントが瞬間的にでてくるんです
まあわかりにくいに動画に流します
シンプルですよでも僕がしたいのは
このコメントを注ぎキャベツ食ってる僕ですよね
生産者の方にしっかりと届けてあげたい
人と人のコミュニケーションは顔が見えないそんな距離感にあってもその距離を感じ
させないようなそういうテクノロジーを開発していきたいです
例えばこれは
現代の農家の工夫なんですけれども
わーキャベツじゃないです今回ももももなんですけど多分うまいんですよ
産まないわけないんです今回のは猛虎は全部うまいんです
彼が qr コード付いてますこの qr コードを
スキャンすると何が出てくるから非常にシンプル
現代の農家さんから現代の消費者の皆様への手紙が出てきます
これねっ
技術的には何も難しくことないし何らブレークスルーを必要としない
ただの工夫ですけど僕はこのアプローチの方法は非常にエレガントだと思うんですね
ものコミュニケーション2.0なんて高尚なことを言いますけれども
とどのつまりはシンプルで人と人がだいぶ離れてもみんなのコミュニケーションは
みんなの意思の疎通はこれまで通り正常に行われていくべきだとこれからもっと離れる
んです
誰が作ったかなってめん
まあそんな世の中にあっても
僕たちはこういうのを作ってまだまだどうやって完成するかなんてたぶん皆さんも
わかんないですぼくだって完璧に見えてわけじゃないすよだって想像できないことって
世の中怒りますよね
左ポケットに本な60 gb なんて入ってるの誰も想像しなかった
けどあきらめない
僕の話は今日はこれで終わりですけれども
ものの向こう側には1だって人のウェットな存在感が確固としてそこにある
その人に届く気持ちもある昔はもっといい子だけどこれから難しくなる
そういうふうに
今日感じていただければ幸いですどうもありがとうございます